compute 23 times 44 and maybe the
hardest part of this problem or maybe
the first hard part is to recognize that
that dot even means multiplication this
could have also been written as 23 times
44 or they could have written it as 23
in parentheses times 44 so you just put
the two parentheses next to each other
that also implies multiplication so now
that we know we're multiplying let's
actually do the problem so we're going
to multiply 23 I'll write it bigger
we're going to multiply 23 by 44 I'll
write the traditional multiplication
sign there just so that we know we're
multiplying it's not when you write it
vertically like this you very seldomly
we very seldom put a dot there so let's
do some multiplication so we start off
let's start off multiplying this four in
the ones place times 23 so you have
three times four is 12 we can write two
in the ones place but then we want to
carry the 1 or we want to regroup that
one in the tens place so it's 12 so you
put the one over here and now you have 4
times 2 is 8 plus 1 is 9 is 9 so you can
think about it is 4 this fort right here
times 23 is 92 that's what we just
solved for now we want to figure out
what this 4 times 23 is now what we do
here is when you just do it mechanically
when you just learn the process you
stick a zero here but the whole reason
why you're putting a zero here is
because you're now dealing with a four
in the tens place if you get another I
don't know a three or four or whatever
digit you're dealing with the hundreds
place you'd put a Z more zeroes here
because we're going to find out the 4
times 23 is 92 we just figure that out
if we just multiply this 4 times 23
again we would get 92 again but this 4
is actually a 40 so it actually should
be 920 and that's why we're putting that
0 now you're going to see it in a second
so we have let me put this in a
different color so this 4 now we're
multiplying 4 times 3 is 12 let's put
the 2 right here it should be in the
tens place because this is really a 40
times the 3 just think about it but or
you could just think over
process is the next space that's free 4
times 3 is 12 carry the 1 this blue one
is from last time you ignore it now you
don't want to mess that up make that
mess it up that's when we multiplied
this 4 so now we have 4 times 2 is 8
plus 1 is 9 is 9 so what we've figured
out so far is 4 times 23 is 92 and this
green 4 times 23 is 920 and that's
because this green 4 actually represents
40 it's in the tens place so when you
multiply 44 times 23 it's going to be 4
times 23 which is 92 plus 40 times 23
which is 920 I just want to make sure we
understand what we're doing here and so
we can take their sum now let's add them
up 2 Plus 0 is 2 9 plus 2 is 11 carry
the 1 1 plus 9 is 10 put a comma here
just so it's easy to read every third
digit so 23 times 44 is 1012